Congresswoman Ilhan Omar is trending
again for her comments about Charlie
Kirk. She doubled down on her claim that
Charlie was an evil man who spread hate.
>> I am not going to sit here and um be uh
judged for not wanting to honor any
legacy this man has left behind. That
should be in the dustpin of history. Uh
and we should hopefully move on and
forget the hate that he spewed every
single day. And Congresswoman Omar finds
it extremely disturbing that so many
people are willing to excuse Charlie's
hateful ideas.
>> What I find jarring is that there are so
many people willing to excuse the most
reprehensible
things that he said, that they agree
with that, that they're willing to have
monuments for him, that they want to
create a day to honor him. Now, I did a
live stream where I went through a bunch
of the accusations of hatred and bigotry
that Charlie's critics have been sharing
over and over again. When we took a
closer look at what Charlie said, it
wasn't even close to what his critics
were claiming that he said. But since I
haven't watched everything Charlie said,
let me go ahead and grant for argument's
sake that he said horribly offensive
things and that his message was simply
bad for society. If I grant that for the
sake of argument, what should happen to
Charlie's legacy according to
Congresswoman Omar?
>> Any legacy this man has left behind that
should be in the dustpin of history.
>> And what should we do? Uh, and we should
hopefully move on and forget the hate
that he spewed every single day.
>> Good to know. But should Congresswoman
Omar's approach only be applied to
Charlie Kirk? Or is she giving us
powerful advice for dealing with anyone
who spreads hate and intolerance? We're
about to find out because I've got a
challenge for Congresswoman Omar. I'll
go ahead and share some basic
information about her prophet and then
we'll get to the challenge. Let's read a
few passages. We'll start with the
Quran. Surah 98 verse 6. Verily those
who disbelieve in the religion of Islam,
the Quran and Prophet Muhammad blah blah
blah from among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians and al-
Mushrakun. Mushrakun are people who
associate partners with Allah will abide
in the fire of hell. They are the worst
of creatures. Jews, Christians, and
other non-Muslims are the worst of
creatures. We're lower than pigs
according to the Quran. But surah 3 vers
110 says that Muslims are the best of
peoples ever raised up for mankind.
Muslims are the best of peoples.
Non-Muslims are the worst of creatures.
Surah 5:51.
Oh you who believe, do not take the Jews
and the Christians for friends. They are
friends of each other. And whoever
amongst you takes them for a friend.
Then surely he is one of them. Surely
Allah does not guide the unjust people.
Muslims aren't allowed to be friends
with Jews or Christians. Surah 48:29.
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah and
those who are with him are severe
against disbelievers and merciful among
themselves. Muslims are severe against
non-Muslims and merciful only among
themselves. In surah 9 29 Allah commands
Muslims to fight those who do not
believe in Allah nor in the latter day
nor do they prohibit what Allah and his
apostle have prohibited nor follow the
religion of truth. Islam out of those
who have been given the book. Those who
have been given the book are Jews and
Christians until they pay the tax and
acknowledgment of superiority and they
are in a state of subjection.
Muhammad certainly didn't want a
pluralistic society. In Sahim Muslim
4594, he said, "I shall certainly expel
the Jews and Christians from the Arabian
Peninsula until I leave only Muslims
there." So Muhammad believed in
expelling people from lands they've been
living in for centuries based on their
religious beliefs. And we know about his
long-term plans for Jews. Sah Muslim
7339.
The messenger of Allah said the hour
will not begin until the Muslims fight
the Jews and the Muslims will kill them.
Until a Jew hides behind a rock or a
tree, and the rock or tree will say, "Oh
Muslim, oh slave of Allah, there is a
Jew behind me. Come and kill him."
Except the gar, a thorny tree, for it is
one of the trees of the Jews.
>> On a completely different note, Muhammad
wouldn't have allowed Congresswoman Omar
to be a leader. In Sah Albkari 1799 he
said never will succeed such a nation as
makes a woman their ruler. Women can't
rule according to Muhammad. If a nation
has a woman as its ruler that nation
will fail. Why? Because according to
Muhammad women such as Congresswoman
Omar are intellectually deficient. In
Sah Bkari 2658 Muhammad said isn't the
witness of a woman equal to half of that
of a man? The women said yes. He said
this is because of the deficiency of a
woman's mind. So women by nature have
deficient minds. But women aren't simply
deficient in intellect. They're also
deficient in religion and they're the
majority in hell. Sahuslam 241. Oh
women, give in charity and pray a great
deal for forgiveness. For I have seen
that you are the majority of the people
of the fire. A wise woman among them
said, "Why is it, oh messenger of Allah,
that we are the majority of the people
of the fire?" He said, "You curse a
great deal and are ungrateful to your
husbands. I have never seen anyone so
deficient in intellect and religion more
overwhelming to a man of wisdom and
reason than you.
Since women are intellectually and
morally deficient according to Muhammad,
they should simply be married off when
they're extremely young so they can be
fully controlled by their husbands. Sah
Bkari 5133.
Notice the chapter heading. Giving one's
young children in marriage is
permissible. Why? By virtue of the
statement of Allah and for those who
have no monthly courses, i.e. they are
still immature. That's surah 65:4 of the
Quran. And the ida, the ida is the
waiting period for passing a girl on to
the next man after you've married her
and had sex with her. For the girl
before puberty is 3 months in the above
verse. Yes, this is talking about
marrying and divorcing prepubescent
girls. And as an example of a man
marrying a prepubescent girl, we have
Muhammad marrying a six-year-old girl
when he was already in his 50s. Narrated
Aisha that the prophet wrote the
marriage contract with her when she was
6 years old and he consummated his
marriage when she was 9 years old and
then she remained with him for 9 years
i.e. till his death. Again, women are
intellectually and morally inferior
according to Muhammad. So what happens
if your wives, especially your child
brides, don't listen? You may not even
be able to reason with them. This is why
husbands may have to simply beat their
wives into submission. Surah 4:34.
Men are in charge of women because Allah
hath made the one of them to excel the
other and because they spend out of
their property for the support of women.
So good women are the obedient, guarding
in secret that which Allah hath guarded.
As for those from whom ye fear
rebellion, admonish them, and banish
them to beds apart, and scourge them.
Then if they obey you, seek not a way
against them. Lo, Allah is ever high,
exalted, great. Putting all of this
together, here's my open challenge to
Congresswoman Ilhan Omar. I guess I
should address her directly.
Congresswoman Omar, if Charlie Kirk's
legacy should be in the dust bin of
history,
>> any legacy this man has left behind that
should be in the dust bin of history.
>> And if we shouldn't excuse the
reprehensible things that someone says,
>> there are so many people willing to
excuse the most reprehensible
things that he said. Shouldn't the
legacy of your child molesting,
Jewhating, spousal abuse promoting,
misogynistic, Islamic supremacist, fake
prophet who commanded his followers not
to be friends with Jews or Christians
and to expel Jews and Christians and to
violently subjugate Jews and Christians?
Shouldn't his legacy be in the dust bin
of history?
>> And we should hopefully move on and
forget the hate that he spewed every
single day. And if you're simply going
to excuse all of the disgusting things
your fake prophet said and did,
shouldn't we conclude that your real
motive in attacking Charlie Kirk isn't
that he was spreading hate, but that he
saw right through you and was exposing
your fake profit.
[Music]